all right time to rake up some kill what
the [ __ ] I hate this [ __ ] shotgun
he's trying to hide from me like oh
where did he go
not there
alright give me a [ __ ] gun I have
that go with the vector I can't shoot
with a [ __ ] what are these plebs
doing in the mid like start of the game
like running around so late without a
weapon like what the [ __ ] are you do
what were you doing
I hear footsteps probably get a [ __ ] out
of that guy someone's left already
where's the yeah we're gonna have to get
out of here I hate [ __ ] I always die
crossing the goddamn [ __ ] bridge oh
alright there best be a [ __ ] you there's
no car are you kidding me
powerful yeah no it's horrible it's so
hard for people hey found a buggy
very nice
since there's no cars I almost want to
just camp on the bridge be that [ __ ]
but I assure you someone else is already
doing it
hello friend is me FPSRussia
camping the bridge what
there's no
oh yeah I already see one walking across
probably going to go looking for a boat
probably better off swimmin where did
that guy go I saw someone where do you
go looking for Bo
[Applause]
I wonder if these have been looted as
another car he followed me
is he doing
come on one [ __ ] boy
I see you
well done bet our [ __ ] ammo on you
thank you what else did you go all right
let's see if these were loaded quick red
dot no red eye
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] just sitting here
look at this [ __ ] do and you start
ahead show me how close he doing like
Expo oh hell yeah get a car that's nice
okay what do we do then keep this and I
guess I'll keep this
let's [ __ ] setting in here he's
letting me heal as well
ah [ __ ] we got to go
okay next stop that's next on the list
what's next
giggles which car
I don't know go here we can wait up the
circle again
might be bad to be honest
think about solely you can actually
drive around in cars no one will
probably show you do well everyone will
[ __ ] spray you down Jesus Christ all
right where's the fiddling oh actually
these they're not that great probably
better off like this one
- ask um I actually did here
someone's like this isn't looted but I
also don't believe it four times tell ya
Oh bleep Stephanie come on
[Music]
[ __ ] just healing up now
these watchtowers are actually pretty
good over you I'm just hoping one of
them will go out and get the [ __ ] car
but it didn't seem like it he's still in
the house
I'm boosting double because we're going
to tank a little bit I'm surprised this
guy has not left its [ __ ] house yet
there he goes
come on fam
you know
[Music]
he said someone throw a [ __ ] nade in
front of him well
it's definitely someone up here other is
look at that but got him the other one
is on top which is the beauty because he
can't [ __ ] leave
okay we got an eight-time scope I'll
call its garbage has [ __ ]
Oh Oh stupid move yeah [ __ ] it
yeah come here c'mere family
very safe or nice office time and shots
nearby
see anyone give am blind I heard shots
down here
this is a weird circle
we shot a better helmet probably sure to
pick that up
everyone's very quiet right now
like how do you where the [ __ ] are you
you're so lame dude you're just going to
distract [ __ ] drag everyone here like
what were you doing
there's no cover right this is
ridiculous I don't know where the other
guy is
I have no cover
you must be on the other side or some
[ __ ]
I hope I don't get a head shot
it's like do I have to do everything in
this [ __ ] circle
right
I'm [ __ ] well confused man
where is he
Oh No
where is he
I wish I had at least some energy drink
I [ __ ] what is he on a tree here
in the bush oh he was in the bush
hahahaha